and i always been fascinated by those
kind of people who are who are really
looking forward to have a great impact
whether you are
in every profession you can have those
kind of people
and those are the people who challenge
society somehow who see things before
and put society in a different in a
different situation because changing
doesn't come
easy never come easy nowadays is much
more
accepted i would say
but in the past that was not the case so
all the people who are driving the
change were questioned by society and
they find themselves in a very difficult
situation
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl
welcome to 20 minute leaders we are in
italy with ms similiano magrini founder
and managing partner of united ventures
massimiliano has always worked at the
intersection of business and technology
that being the threat across his career
from launching the operations of alta
vista and google italy as founding
country manager to creating an event
avant-garde vc studio in 2009 and then
co-founding in 2013 united ventures the
milan based independent venture capital
from investing in the digital
technologies today massimiliano's
mission is to back extraordinary
founders along their journey to build
great companies from the early to the
growth stage he provides strategic
guidance to portfolio companies and
leads the investment thesis on
game-changing technologies aimed at the
creation of long-term value
mr emiliano magrini welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you very good thank you
thank you so much for joining me here
and for inviting me to your beautiful
offices uh i i'm not sure if we can see
the duomo perhaps behind the
behind the wall there but we're in the
center of milan
and i'm in one of the most prosperous
venture capital firms in milan and and
your history with venture capital but
with tech the tech ecosystem in general
is phenomenal and your understanding of
the tech ecosystem in milan is is
amazing and i'm excited to pick your
brain in these 20 minutes
mr millennial who who are you actually i
just want to say that this building in
particular was the home of the worker of
the duomo
really this building yeah this building
okay so
who are you massimiliano uh so actually
i as you said i'm the co-founder of
united ventures today one of the largest
we see in italy we started back in 2012
and we started just because i was before
that i was an angel investors
and uh the thing is that when you are an
angel investor you always think that
there are venture capital being able to
pick up on the right things that you are
investing in
but unfortunately in 2012 there was not
enough venture capital in italy so
basically we transformed my activity as
an angel investor we we joined forces
with my actual partner that was doing bc
before and we built united ventures that
the name itself tells the story of two
entity combining themselves into united
ventures so the the greater context here
is we're in italy we're in milan what is
the what does the tech ecosystem look
like in italy both in terms of the
startup scene and but also the venture
capital scene
sure i mean
i think in every ecosystem there is one
city that somehow bring
that
critical mass and becoming the
national hub in that sense milan is the
nation the italian national hub like
madrid is in spain or france is in the
same
[Music]
piracy in france or london uh used to be
actually a continental level
um the thing is that in italy we are i
think where maybe israel was in uh more
than ten years ago i mean well there is
a um a growing ecosystem there are there
are all the the components right now
and i you can think of italy like the
emerging country within an emerging
continent that's the way i look at it
right now and so what is that tangible
we mean an emerging country within an
emerging continent because there is a
misallocation between entrepreneurial
talent and venture capital availability
so if you compare italy to
our i would say friends from spain or
france we have 10 to 20 times less
venture capital availability to
enterprise wow
and you can say you cannot say that we
are 10 to 20 percent less
entrepreneurial than the spanish or the
french entrepreneurs so there is a
misallocation that we think is a great
opportunity in reality so so the way
that you're approaching instead of
saying this is a temporary scene because
obviously we're we have amazing people
in both places yet the discrepancy and
the gap between the amount of capital
that's just a matter of time until
somebody picks up on it and we're going
to be the ones to pick up on it exactly
and the one thing that really can
inflate this process is having strong
local investors
lead investors who can definitely bridge
the opportunity to the other
international investor and that's
basically the dna of united ventures
right now so where do you come from are
you you're a local from italy right i
was born in italy yes and and how do you
grow up into the tech world because
that's not a trivial thing to do right
yeah yeah yeah i i turned into a
technological multinational company back
in 2000 when there was the bubble
basically back then and i was there in
2000 when
everybody was going up and then all of a
sudden everything went down
but
i stayed there i i actually i joined
first alta vista which was the first
search engine at the time and afterward
i joined google in 2002
i stayed the course of the industry when
nobody was really
thinking that the industry would have
picked up once again
and that
and that suddenly happened google went
public and then facebook went public and
everybody realized that there was a
future for the tech scene
and
and that's basically my background i i
used to work for technology company that
at the time were startups and then they
grew up to become large corporation
right and so you're leaving google in
2009 you're starting and you're you're
investing actively and you start united
ventures in 2012 right and
now we're in 2021 and and you have a
multitude of funds from very early also
to growth and you're able to write
significant tract sizes here in the
industry you mentioned that
most of your investments are are local
within italy but you also do some
outside right yeah the the court this is
where we started was to back italian
entrepreneur really to build global
company
and that's where we started and then we
ended we invested also in a company
based in london based in u.s there was
we invest in a company based in israel
that move eventually in the us
we can say 60 of our courtesies is still
around italian entrepreneurs willing to
build global company and the rest is
europe and the rest of the world right
and and so one of the bigger questions
that vcs are dealing with themselves
especially i know in paula santovi is
this question of deal flow and how do
you even get access to the right
entrepreneurs
what is that like for you here in italy
yeah i think that overall i think any vc
has his own dna of being positioned in
the market being perceived in the market
that's something that for a long time uh
even the strongest we see neglected the
idea of being able to position
themselves which is not the case every
bc has a dna and is perceived from the
outside so i think if you look at united
ventures somehow is perceived like the
fact that we see if you want to go and
build from italy and international based
and mindset companies
and that's where our sweet spot is
compare all to the other visas we have
in italy
because we have been building upon this
thesis from from a long time we have
been uh funding smart entrepreneurs that
show that there is a path starting from
italy and building global company and
then this is something that uh basically
we we own as a position
right and so
share with me a little bit about the
relationship that you have with the
entrepreneurs once they're wedding
because you're mentioning italian a lot
of locals that are thinking about global
companies but that requires a lot of
role models and mentorship right
especially if the if the industry is not
yet
doesn't have the anchors inside of it
that's pretty true
i i start the idea of doing venture
capital
by the idea of working with
entrepreneurs the reason why i like this
job is working with entrepreneurs
of course in the venture capital you are
you have to do many things different
things you have to raise money you have
to manage your partnership manage
investment manager there is a lot of
management work to be done but the the
most important part is the work you do
with the entrepreneurs and that's the
reason why i started this job
in particular when i started in reality
in europe uh venture capital was more
prestigious like an asset class instead
of uh
i mean an industry supporting
entrepreneurs so there were more a lot
of formal
managing of processes contracts and
stuff like that and little attention was
paid to the real value-added value that
you do with the enterprise so right when
i started i i started with the idea of
work with entrepreneurs that was that
this uh
the thing that i was
doing when i was an angel investor as
well
so the idea was combining the formal
process of vc the the backing of lps
together with this hands-on approach
with the entrepreneurs which is
the fact pretty obvious in many parts of
the world but not still very
very common in many places i think still
venture capital is pretty formal in that
sense and uh working with the
entrepreneurs is what differentiate i
think one vc to the other right so tell
me a few companies that you're working
with you have
hundreds of millions of dollars under
management you're backing some some
really cool companies share with me some
specific ones that just for context
so yeah we we started basically united
venture was born by investing in a
company called money farm which is
london-based asset manager
and and that's basically when there was
not even fintech award
there out there so nobody was thinking
that the asset management was one of the
key sector and fit tech as well
and that was in 2013 now uh we we so
that's said to be to show that we like
to be very early on the thesis we don't
like to follow
uh momentum investing these which are
over over uh hyped for instance we like
to invest pretty early in the in the
sector
so another example i can make we
invested in a cyber security company
focused on firmware cyber security
which is very specific there are three
companies in the world doing that and
one is uh israeli of course
and we invested in uh farm technologies
so
technology will help
digitize the process of farming for
instance we did it a couple of years ago
when
actually there were very few funds right
that sector we invested in a company
which is doing uh software stimulation
for uh
pharma and medical devices industries
funny enough
realized how important is the the
pharmaceutical industry
but still they are not using the same
amount of software that other industries
are using so if you are flying on a
plane or driving a car there is a lot of
software simulation involved in
deploying that kind of model this thing
this software is not used for developing
drugs for instance right
and so we invested in a company which
tried to capture that kind of uh
initiative so just to
to name some of the thesis we are very
keen on now this idea of investing
before the market right and going
against the grain or or saying you know
there's a lot of momentum somewhere but
we actually believe something a little
bit else and we want to be unique that's
a really scary thing to do right as i
mean i'm guessing as a venture capital
isn't it
actually i think it ultimately is the
dna of venture capital because otherwise
if it's purely momentum investing it's
pure amount of money to be deployed then
you become an asset manager
that moment you become an asset manager
if you are an early stage investor you
can not afford to be an asset manager i
think you have to be early in in in
showing finding the right entrepreneurs
in the sector you want to be actually
it's not very different from what i've
done in back in 2000 i was working in
established industry i was a corporate
there and i have i had all the perks and
the salary when i left to join startups
back in 2000 everybody was questioning
why i was doing that and everybody still
was questioning when i left google to
become an angel investor and that's it's
part of the same thinking i think you
want to you you see something happening
and you would you would just want to be
part of that amazing so if you're
looking at the italian ecosystem right
now and and the different entrepreneurs
are there what are some patterns that
you think what what is the room for
growth so what is what is the where is
the next milestone to reach as a country
as an ecosystem together not a specific
startup
sure i mean if you look at the pattern
by which an ecosystem develop over time
it's pretty similar in europe the path
is pretty
it happened the same way in different
countries so
first and foremost you need a strong uh
lead investors at the beginning which
somehow is
publicly involved that same thing is
happening in israel right i think and it
happened in spain it happened in france
it happened in the uk so you needed this
you need to show that there is
commitment from the government by
supporting this industry and lowering
the risk of private capital then
of course over time private capital will
overcome the public money and the public
can can stay away from the market but at
the beginning it's very important to
show that there is strong belief that
that that is the the the way to go
and uh actually in italy is happening uh
the same way so we had a strong local
lead investor which is the cdp like the
national promotion agency that show that
there is a big commitment on that and
over time
private money is coming
and basically getting more share of the
overall investing uh
right a venture capital
uh
amount of money deployed on a yearly
basis and that's basically what happened
across the board
now is it a common or a mainstream
thought i'm gonna be an entrepreneur i'm
gonna grow up in in milan or in rome and
i'm gonna after university i'm gonna
create my own company yeah it's becoming
across the world that's not like typical
italian typical israel i mean in israel
it's pretty evident but is becoming the
factor uh
if you look back in the 90s everybody
was willing to go banking and live in
london that was the the the topic now is
everybody is willing to do tech
entrepreneurs whatever and because there
are apps uh there are national hubs
continental labs and uh
and world labs uh hubs of technology and
this
idea of becoming a technological
enterprise is definitely
common in the world i don't think it's a
trait of a country or a city it's
definitely something uh i would say um
generational and how dramatically has
this changed over the last 10 or 15
years here because you've been here for
a while yeah it's just changed
dramatically so still 10 years ago
people were still willing to go and work
for consultancy company big banks
nowadays the most talented people that
you want to or either to join or start
their own company right
now to take me back to 2009 so you
mentioned that you you left a big
corporate very successful position
country manager for google and to to
become an angel investor yeah going to
the other spectrum what was the thinking
process in your mind and i'm trying to
get into your brain now
what is your thinking process and you're
saying you know what i think i think i
want to make an impact somewhere else
right now
i think it's it's always
the same path so you start thinking on
what's next and you try to anticipate
what's going to happen next and i kind
of envisioned this idea of
the technology industry to become bigger
and more important for for societies and
so the demand for venture capital will
have grown eventually over time
but the
what kind of venture capital a different
kind of venture capital venture cup have
been able to work and uh on with the
entrepreneurs and helping them scale
the company and you cannot do that if
you if you don't have
that kind of problem which are hiring
firing raising money right those are i
would say operational problems if you
look from a purely i would say abstract
perspective of being an asset manager
that's very difficult for you to deal
with the entrepreneurs so that was the
idea and i just think that i had a great
time at google and it was the experience
of my life from a professional
standpoint but i was my mind was always
thinking about what's next and that was
the past for me
and entrepreneur and by nature for what
i'm hearing so amazing i really want to
go back a little bit in time to your
childhood i want to understand a little
bit about your upbringing so what really
fascinated you as you're growing up so
what what is it i'm trying to understand
what leads a person to do and get to the
point where we're at now in the center
of milan and there's these beautiful
offices what fascinated you
i mean i i
i always think about whatever great
impact so you can have a great impact by
being a politician a doctor you can
choose whatever profession you have but
at the end of the day there are people
who have
who desperately need
to have an impact and people are fine
just following
what's going on and this is somehow
differentiating between people and i
always been fascinated by those kind of
people who was who are really looking
forward to have a great impact whether
you are
in every profession you can have those
kind of people
and those are the people who challenge
society somehow who see things before
and put society in a different in a
different situation because changing
doesn't come
easy never come easy nowadays it's much
more
accepted i would say
but in the past that was not the case so
all the people who are driving the
change were questioned by society and
they find themselves in a very difficult
situation and sometimes you will really
have to
to challenge your life you know just to
sustain your
your beliefs
and this is something that has always
fascinated myself i i just
wrote a book a couple of years ago
around those
divergent thinkers who are the one who
had an impact in society and
we are in italy and basically if you
study leonardo da vinci he was a
divergent thinker by nature he just
he wasn't
happy with this explanation was getting
from the people around himself so he
questioned everything and redesigned the
reality in order to fit his views
amazing amazing and what inspires you
today so as you you're deciding to
continue you raised your third fund
amazing
what inspires you to keep on going and
to keep doing what you're doing
yeah i mean the challenge is always the
same one when we started this one nobody
was believing in italy that we could
have done what we were doing because
everybody was challenging ah it can
happen in italy why in italy we are not
good at that which is i find it very
stupid by the way
but even the people from outside italy
was not thinking that in italy could
have done that i was talking with my
friend the united states there was a
technology in italy why do you just
focus on cars or in food on this kind of
things so whenever technology basically
become a layer for every kind of
industry that you you understand that
that was not the case and of course now
it's pretty evident that
entrepreneurship can come from anywhere
you don't have to be all everybody
located in one single place in order to
get venture capital and to escape
company 100
and what are the three words you would
use to describe yourself
well i would say it can be pretty
evident that i combine a couple of
things but i have to be passionate if
i'm not passionate i cannot drive
results
i'm very curious and basically i like to
challenge everything so i don't take for
granted almost anything similar thank
you very very much thank you this is
wonderful take care best of luck with
the fun and this is amazing thank you
very much
you